before we talk about the debt ceiling
it's important to realize the difference
between the deficit the deficit and the
debt because these words are thrown
around and it's clear that they're
related but sometimes people might
confuse one for the other the deficit is
how much you overspend in a given year
while the debt is the total amount the
cumulative amount of debt you've you've
gotten over many many years so let's
take a look I guess a very simplified
example let's say you have some type of
a country and that country spends in a
given year that country spends ten
dollars but it's only bringing in six
dollars in tax revenue so it's bringing
in in taxes it's only bringing in six
dollars so this country and this year
where it spends ten dollars even though
it only has six dollars to spend it has
a four dollar it has a four dollar
deficit $4 D EF is short for deficit and
well let me just write it out and I
think it's defense or something it has a
four dollar deficit and you might say
well how does it how does it spend more
money than it brings in how can it how
can it actually continue to spend this
much where will it get the four dollars
from and the answer is it will borrow
that four dollars our little country
will borrow it and so the debt may be
going into this year the country already
had some debt maybe it already had $100
of debt and so in this situation it
would have to borrow another $4 of debt
and so exiting this year it would have a
hundred and four dollars of debt it
would have a hundred and four dollars of
debt if the country runs the same four
dollar deficit the year after this then
the debt will increase to 108 dollars if
it runs another four dollar deficit then
the debt will increase to a hundred and
twelve dollars now that we have that out
of the way let's think about what the
debt ceiling is so you can imagine the
United States actually does its
continuing to run a deficit its
continuing to spend more than it brings
in and actually for the United States
these ratios are appropriate do you not
for every dollar that the United States
spends right now 40% 40% is borrowed or
another way to think about it only it
only
has 60% of every dollar that it needs to
spend right now so it has to go out into
the debt markets and borrow 40% to keep
spending at its current rate and so if
it's continuing to borrow you can
imagine that the debt keeps on
increasing the debt keeps on increasing
so let me draw a little graph here so
that access is time this axis right over
here is the total cumulative
amount of debt that we have we continue
to have to borrow 40 percent of every
dollar that we're spending and so our
debt is continuing to increase
so our debt is continuing to increase
and Congress has the power or Congress
has the authority to essentially limit
how much debt we have so right now we
have a current debt limit of fourteen
point three trillion dollars so this is
fourteen point three trillion dollars
and I even though Congress has this
authority the way that it's worked in
the past is it's kind of just a rubber
stamp Congress has just always allowed
the debt ceiling to go up and up and up
to fund our borrowing costs and if you
think about it that kind of makes sense
because right now Congress is the one
that decides where to spend the money
what are the obligations and so the debt
ceiling is like oK we've already agreed
what you have to spend your money on
Congress has to determine Congress is
the one that figures out what we spend
our money on and what our taxes are and
so they say look we've already
determined how much you have to borrow
it would seem kind of ridiculous for us
after we've determined how much you
borrow to say that you cannot borrow it
you can act you cannot actually do what
we've told you to do and so historically
Congress has just kind of gone with the
flow they said okay yeah we've told you
you need to borrow more money to to
execute on you know it's the executive
branch has to run the government for you
to actually run the government based on
the budget we told you so they just keep
upping it and the last time the debt
ceiling was raised was actually very
recently February 12 2010 it was raised
from twelve point three trillion it was
raised from twelve point actually twelve
point four trillion to the fourteen
point three trillion and this happens
pretty regularly it's happened ten times
since 2001 seventy four times since 1962
so it's just a regular operating thing
and right now we the Obama
administration says look we've actually
come up against our debt ceiling we want
to raise it and ideally for the Obama
administration they want to raise it by
about two point four trillion so they
want to raise it to sixteen point seven
trillion which will kind of put it off
the table for a little bit put it past
the elections so that we don't have to
debate this any more the Republicans on
the other side want to essentially use
this and this is a little bit unusual to
use this as leverage to essentially
reduce the deficit and not only to
reduce the deficit but in particular to
reduce the deficit through spending cuts
and so that's why it's become this big
game of chicken and why we're going up
against this limit now one thing that
that you may or may not realize is that
we actually already hit the debt limit
the current debt limit and we hit that
debt limit on may may 16th 2011 I'm
making this video at the end of July in
2011 and the only reason why the country
is continuing to operate and the only
reason why the country has continued has
been able to continue to pay interest on
its obligations and pay issue Social
Security checks and support Medicare and
and and buy fuel for aircraft carriers
and all the rest is that Geithner who's
the Treasury secretary has been able to
find cash and other places cash normally
set aside for employee pensions and all
the rest and has essentially done a
little bit of a bookkeeping taking money
from one place to another but what he
said what he's publicly said is that
he'll be able he won't be able to do
that anymore as of August 8th August 2nd
2011 so this right here is the date that
everyone is paying attention to August
2nd 2011 according to Geithner at that
point he won't be able to find random
pockets of cash here and there and
shuffled around and you know what he
calls extraordinary measures and at that
point the United States will not be able
to fulfill all of its obligations and so
if you think about all of the
obligations of the United States this is
a huge oversimplification here so this
bar is represents all of the obligations
some of those obligations are things
like things like well it's interest on
the
that at our do is at our do is a huge
amount of debt fourteen point three
trillion dollars things like Social
Security Medicare Medicare defense
defense and then all of the other stuff
that the companies the the country that
the country has to has to support all of
their other obligations so if as of
August 2nd 2011 we cannot issue any more
debt and Geithner can't doesn't have any
extra cash laying around with these
extraordinary measures then the the only
option if those are the only options on
the table the only option is to somehow
reduce some of these things by 40%
because 40% of every dollar we used to
spend on all of these obligations 40%
are borrowed and so something over here
is going to give we're not going to
fulfill our obligations to one or more
of these things all of these things that
we are legally obligated to fulfill that
Congress has says these are the things
that the United States should be
spending its money on and so at that
point it is perceived that we would have
to default and a default actually would
be on any of its obligations but in
particular we could be we especially if
we have to cut everything by 40% and we
don't want to see retirees you know not
be able to you know get evicted from
their houses or aircraft carriers not
have fuel or whatever else we might
defer or have try to restructure or do
something weird with our debt in which
case we would be defaulting and I want
to be clear a default it's usually
referred to not fully paying the
interest on debt that you owe but it
would be a default would be any of its
obligations the United States has this
triple-a rating if the United States
says it's gonna give you a Social
Security check you trust that if the
United States says that it's gonna it's
gonna pay for that Medicare payment you
trust that if it if it says it's going
to give you an interest payment you
trust that all of a sudden if the United
States does not fulfill any of those
obligations then all of the obligations
become suspect and the reason why this
is a big deal is you can imagine if if
you borrow money and you've always been
good at paying back that money you're
going to have you're gonna pay lower
interest than other people would have to
pay but all of a sudden for whatever
reason one day you default you either
delay your payments or you say you don't
have the cash to pay your payments
then people's like wow you're a much
riskier risk you're a much riskier
person to lend money to so now I'm going
to increase the interest rates on you
and so the perception is is that the
United States were to default on its
debt or any of its obligations that
interest rates that interest rates would
go up and the reason why this would
really kind of not be great is because
it would make the debt and the deficit
even worse
then we would then this chunk is going
to have to grow our obligations are on
debt as as new debt gets issued we're
gonna have to pay more and more interest
so it's gonna just make matters worse
it's gonna make the deficit worse and on
top of that it's not just that the
government's debt the interest on the
government's debt will go up but
government but interest on all debt in
the United States will probably go up
because government debt is perceived to
be the safest it's the benchmark a lot
of other debt contracts are actually
tied to government debt so you'll have
interest rates throughout the economy go
up which is exactly what you do not want
to happen when you are either in a
recession or when you are recovering
from a recession